hello thank you for joining us today
participants from all over the world
will be attending a lab roots v EMU
microbiology in immunology conference
this virtual event is a global platform
to learn about earth and human
management of our microbial wealth
emergency Diagnostics new methods and
emerging trends in approaches to
vaccines and antimicrobial resistance
and new insights into virology the aim
of microbiology mythology 2019 is to
bring together renowned experts from
academia and industry leading by a
medical scientist healthcare
professionals in top research scholars
to share the best possible research and
provide new advancements in solutions
adopted in the areas of microbiology
immunology pathogenesis and related
fields the 2-day agenda will feature
over 18 presenters highlighting topics
including metagenomics microbial
communities vie rooms and virus host
interactions structural virology and
much more the opening keynote speakers
dr. Jonathan Shimon co-founder and chief
executive officer of fitb omics dr.
Shimon will address mining athlete's
microbiomes for next generational
probiotics and kicking off day two my
keynote address will explore microbial
centric aging a paradigm shift unmasking
the growing awareness of our microbiota
in wellness and disease and promote the
concept of microbial banking and
microbial based economics be sure to
enter the exhibit hall and Explorer
showcased technologies at the booths and
engage real-time with sponsor
representatives on the latest
innovations in microbiology and
immunology on behalf of the invited
presenters and sponsors welcome lab
roots is pleased to bring you this
online symposium and such an informative
and educational experience enjoy
you